et maintenant dans là où ça bouge un
coup de coeur avec cet album willaert
fait par trois à cannes et trois cas les
musiciens mais il fallait un quatrième
homme pour mettre tout ça en relief
il s'appelle sylvain on va le rencontrer
ici dans un studio accord sinon vous
avez réalisé cet album réalisé c'est à
dire vous avez mis tous les sons en
harmonie en commencer quoi réaliser un
album je propose out a commencé à
m'envoyer des morceaux voilà savoir ce
que je peux faire et ça s'est fait petit
à petit en fait parce que c'est avant
tout c'est des relations de confiance
entre la personne qui a la technique et
les artistes qui eux vous apporte un
bébé qui n'est pas encore tout à fait
fini
le projet quand je les ai eues il était
déjà bien avancé en fait ils m'ont dit
juste cela voilà qu'est ce que tu peux
en faire
j'avais beaucoup de liberté au final
donc ça c'était super
c'était sa leçon de base à partir de
sainté voilà de deux doigts de deux
pistes de santé donc l'idée de base
c'est ça alors moi mon travail c'était à
partir de ces indications là d'essayer
de recréer une ambiance deviennent
évocateurs d'une fête foraine ça donne
ça donne
dans ses morceaux dans ces structures
j'ai essayé d'apporter du grain j'ai
essayé de faire que les batteries soient
un peu plus consistant que parce que et
la basse aussi pour que cet ensemble
il est une bonne assise et après tout
les santé les guitares et puis si
naturellement
comment vous allez faire sur scène comme
vous allez retrouver le son cet album là
ça va être un gros défi quand l'euro va
jouer en live alors je sais pas si si le
but c'est de recréer exactement l'album
sur ça je pense pas parce que l'idée ce
sera peut-être d'apporter justement
quelque chose de d'humains entre
guillemets parce qu'il ya le choeur
antique la grille d'arte dans là où ça
bouge un gros coup de coeur pour cet
album avec trois cannes et qu'on espère
voir très vite sur scène
en attendant vous pouvez trouver un
album sur internet donc n'hésitez pas et
puis des vignes aidera beaucoup de 1905
possibilités natalie boileau donne tout
sauf la recette qui toute sa vie à
manger me disais je sais pas encore je
choisis la nourriture et les bornes ce
samedi au theil sur huisne mais pas de
maladie non il est mort en pleine forme
à 57 ans écrasée écrasé par un camion de
livraison de chez naturalia là où ça
bouge à la fabrique du chemin vert pour
surprendre en pleine répétition
les comédiens du festival conséquence
c'est du théâtre forum vas-y fais
d'accord elle est en moi comme un poison
et je te jure sada que moi la première
je prendrai les grenades
je prendrai la dynamite les bombes les
textes que vous allez présenter
rapidement qui qui est l affiche alors
la fiche du brecht
il ya du pin teurs il ya d'une élite
gorce
il ya d'une émeraude ski une de mes
copines aperçoit le commandant du
régiment écrit act qui va là excusez moi
mais je vais tirer
vous imaginez elle lui crie excusez moi
l'idée en fait c'est de créer un support
qui permettra aux gens de s'exprimer
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez un
petit peu de cas vous madame
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de de ce
texte qu'est ce que ça vous raconte
c'est à dire qu'on lit un texte
et on espère que ça suscite un débat
dans la salle voilà surtout on permet
aux gens de d'esprit mais des
observations des critiques sur le texte
sur la compréhension du texte
les anglais ont débarqué sceptiques
j'interroge ou en normandie en êtes-vous
certaine on rappelle que festival
conséquences comme son nom l'indiqué
parle des conséquences de la seconde
guerre mondiale les conséquences que
nous vivons encore aujourd'hui
voilà c'est la troisième édition c'est
la troisième édition est aujourd'hui en
fait elle est carrément au coeur de la
situation puisque on a eu les élections
en août régie on a différents événements
il ya la crise des réfugiés on trouve
des paramètres qui sont qui ressemble
beaucoup aux prémices du deuxième
conflit mondial tué un travailleur c'est
donc que tu travailles
si tu fais grève et ne travaillent pas
alors tu n'es plus un travailleur mais
un individu dangereux et je dois alors
passer aux actes ça se passera le
dimanche 5 juin salle du tombeur à 18h à
la dernière voilà pour les citoyens qui
aiment le théâtre qui ont envie d'en
parler aussi ceux qui s'engagent en
merci